okay hi everybody Welcome we're going to
get started
my name is Daniel Martinez hosang I'm a
faculty member in ethnicity race and
migration I can't uh just tell you how
amazing it is to see on a brutally cold
uh afternoon
um uh how great it is and the warmth uh
that we sense in here for this really
really important conversation
um I'm gonna just do and I'm going to
moderate I'll introduce our speakers in
a moment but
um just start by a couple of the you
know there's a lot a lot of work that
went into pulling this off in just a
couple of days
so I we first want to thank our
colleagues in the Yale education studies
program and especially the director Mira
Debs we just worked tirelessly together
[Applause]
um I'll introduce in a moment our
colleague Paul Van Tassel from the
Senate but a lot of this this I mean
this event is sponsored principally by
the Yale faculty Senate and it means an
enormous amount that our colleagues
across many many departments and
programs and schools understand that
when we're saying there's something very
very serious happening in our discipline
in our world that they respond to that
call and want to know more about it and
want to know how they can be engaged so
we're grateful to the Yale faculty
Senate to the Gilder Lerman Center
the anti-racist teaching and learning
Collective and the many teachers who are
involved with that
African-American studies my colleague
Jason Stanley and of course the
African-American policy Forum so just
first please join me in thanking all of
our co-sponsors
I'll also just say you know our
aspiration here is to listen to one
another to learn from one another
um uh I imagine anyone that had any
Shady plans to disrupt this event would
find it too cold to be outside uh and
make their way here but uh we're looking
forward to uh generative
um uh exchanges that can help us all
become sharper thinkers and actors okay
so with that I want to invite my
colleague Paul to come up and just say a
few words on behalf of the Yale faculty
Senate and then we'll get into our panel
thank you
[Applause]
thank you Professor I was saying uh it's
just I'm delighted to be here today to
lead the Senate this year uh and to help
sponsor such an event uh that the Senate
stands fully behind uh promoting these
types of events where uh where we engage
in dialogue we listen to one another we
learn from one another and especially
when the room is so packed that that
people can can hardly sit um
so again I'm Paul Van Tassel I'm the hap
I'm a professor in chemical and
environmental engineering here at Yale
uh this year I happen to be chair of the
faculty Senate maybe many of you are
students you might not know we have a
faculty Senate we do have a faculty
Senate it's a little bit like your Yale
College Council or the graduate student
assembly it's the principal governing
structure of Faculty here at uh at Yale
University and we're excited about a lot
of our activities among them sponsoring
uh wonderful events like this and
principle maybe as the single unifying
topic that we that we address as a
senate is this concept of academic
freedom I think everybody knows I know
students are here from many different
levels but uh uh academic freedom is
basically as it sounds right it's the
freedom as a professor to teach what we
feel should be taught to research what
we feel should be researched and to
engage in dialogue freely uh and then
debate freely about what what we feel is
important the same principles hold for
students uh uh too and and other and
other Educators uh we feel feel for me
perhaps it's my most cherished aspect of
my job is that uh that I have the
freedom to uh to do those things and
today's topic strikes really at the
heart of of of academic freedom the
Senate among it's other activities
recently has released a resolution uh
speaking against these so-called
educational gag orders it's a uh it's a
phenomena that goes beyond just the the
discussion that we'll we'll have today
but but it encompasses the discussion
we'll have today and these have to do
with legislations that that might act to
restrict academic freedoms on on various
levels
um and so again we're very very happy to
uh to be able to sponsor this important
event and I should point out too that uh
today's uh teaching no matter who is
presenting this would be a very
important topic and one certainly worthy
of uh of a nice discussion but in fact
uh in this case we have two individuals
that have been targeted by such uh such
legislation so my own Yale colleague
Frederick Ferguson and colleague of
sorts but from Columbia Kim Kimberly
Crenshaw who themselves have been
targeted in their academic freedom has
been uh put in Jeopardy uh
at least potentially by these these
types of legislation so it's that let me
again welcome everybody and I look
forward to a great discussion thank you
[Applause]
thank you right so I'm going to do uh
and I should also mention our
like desha brabham who is a member of
the anti-racist teaching and learning
Collective a brilliant teacher at
Windsor high school was not able to come
today I suspect she's watching on the
live stream so hidesha I'm going to do
my best to incorporate some of the
comments that Dacia shared with us in
advance I'm going to say something very
quick to try to kind of get us on the
same page as best I can about what's
happened in the last couple of weeks and
then we're going to do a series of kind
of rounds to get each of the panelists
in conversation with one another what
are they seeing hearing noticing what
are the opportunities throughout
there'll be a chance for you to share
your questions for the panelists and um
with a brilliant aapf staff will help to
kind of curate them so that we can
engage your questions at the end and
then I think at 5 30 we'll all be going
upstairs for the reception afterwards
and have a chance to talk okay
um
so over the last 10 years the College
Board which is formerly a non-profit but
is responsible for administering all the
standardized tests that many students
were subjected to in this room uh as
well as uh AP courses advanced placement
courses which of course are intended to
resemble college courses and in many
cases offer college credit to develop a
course in African-American studies the
very fact that after many many decades
the AP first decided that it would be
finally appropriate to do this is an
effect of many many students and faculty
and Scholars and Advocates demanding the
uh inclusion of these bodies of
knowledge about two weeks ago maybe a
little more the governor of Florida Ron
DeSantis and the education department
announced there had been previous drafts
circulated all AP courses are often done
in close collaboration with college
faculty who are experts in their field
because they're intended to replicate
what a college course would be
um announce that that the course had no
educational value for Florida students
and a day or two later released a
graphic trying to identify bodies of
both Scholars and bodies of knowledge
that it said would not be taught to
Florida high school students until
the College Board revised that among the
scholars listed were our colleagues
Professor Crenshaw Professor Ferguson
battle hooks Angela Davis bodies of
knowledge including queer studies social
movements abolition Etc
by some coincidence three days later as
the story unfolds the College Board
announced that in its revised curriculum
all of those thinkers and bodies of
knowledge and many more had now been
moved to an optional section so they
were effectively and effectively when
students could study them as essay
topics uh and and would uh for further
discussion and disavowed that it was in
any way related to the earlier round of
criticism and we'll talk about some of
the reasons they they cited so here we
are now today the College Board
effectively signing off on a kind of
hiving off and sanitizing of the
curriculum and thinking about what was
at stake who was named in those
exclusions and what the loss is and how
that reverberates so for the first round
of questions
um well hi Kim
um welcome uh so um and and Kim and the
aapf of course been crucial since the
attacks on critical race Theory began
three years ago now I think that's right
and helping us think about the link
between what's happening in Florida what
a resolution that we may be paying
attention to in Texas and kind of a
broad set of concerns so I want to ask
each of you
um and I'll just I'm going to do these
super quick our colleague David blight
in history Jason Stanley and philosophy
and Roger Ferguson and women in gender
studies uh ER M and African-American
studies it has been a whirlwind just a
whirlwind from the time we started
planning this right two other chapters
have unfolded so I just want to first
start we're going to get into the
analysis the unpacking but I want to get
a sense of what you've seen right what's
what across all of this the headlines
the claims the dignities what stood out
to you
um and and maybe to share a moment or uh
yeah something you read that really kind
of captures it so that'll be our first
try and then we'll go from there and Kim
I'd love to start with you all right
well
um good afternoon everyone when I heard
about the weather I thought there'd be
five people here so I am overwhelmed
um so um great to be here so I want to
talk about
um the headlines because those are those
are the things that uh in in my mind re
uh reinforce one of the problems that
we've been seeing for two years and that
is the way the media have functioned
somewhat as a third arm uh in this
effort to politicize the university to
demonize uh critical race Theory
intersectionality in particular
um and to create what in its best
moments is both sidesism but sometimes
it doesn't even arise to that level so
he here's here's one of the headlines
from The New York Times
desantises take DeSantis takes on the
education establishment and builds his
brand
so let's just Ponder this for a moment
right this is basically this could come
from the sports page you know
um a general manager of exonet's Team
you know acquires such and such and
they're in line for the Super Bowl it's
sort of treating some of the most
significant challenges to our democracy
as a question of branding as a question
of is this going to be the strategy that
puts them into the White House you don't
get a sense in this headline that what
we're looking at is the attack on public
education the attack on more than 70
years of building a civil rights
infrastructure that's backed up by and
Amplified by the kind of work that
people who are deeply invested in
addressing the history of this country
in its contemporary implications for our
current democracy you don't get a sense
that any of that is in there so for me
this is an illustration of how what
we're facing is not just a coordinated
organized and well-funded campaign on
the part of those who seek to make
racism erasable to those who seek to
make black history basically ended 1960
we're also fighting against a media
that's taken a kind of well maybe maybe
not kind of approaching now with the
presidential campaign it's turning into
to more of the sort of sports commentary
I I suggest that we think about what
some some Alternatives might have been
to that maybe
um you know the war against academic
freedom uh uh takes a victory right the
the war is against us
um has gotten an important Victory under
its belt or uh uh black studies is the
next venue in the war against academic
freedom that would give you a little bit
more of a sense of what is going on or
maybe college board and DeSantis align
in their blow to academic freedom right
does that get us a little bit closer or
how about this DeSantis unveils his
racially charged strategy to the White
House
maybe that gets us a little bit closer
but I would say it just reinforced how
much the media is also a site of
contestation In This Moment yeah
holding of events that's just a kind of
campaign curiosity spectacle right to do
that though okay
um Rod let's turn to you you know I I
imagine you're I had just this thought
you were I don't know getting ready to
like yeah I think you could just turn it
yeah
reason one says microphone you know
you might have turned it off and on yeah
all right can you hear me yeah yeah all
right good yeah um yes so Rod you were
thrust in the middle of this I imagine
like without much notice you wrote a
brilliant piece in the Chronicle of
Higher Education which everyone should
read uh what is what stands out to you
see everybody I see some of mine in the
room
um former students uh so great to see
all of you and also colleagues uh I
think that
for me it you know the headlines that
suggested the sort of degrading of
critical thinking and critical pedagogy
you know those were the things that
stuck out so one headline is the College
Board strips down its AP curriculum for
African-American studies the official
course looks different from a previous
draft no more critical race Theory and
the study of contemporary topics like
black lives matter is optional so I used
to teach writing right that's how I cut
my teeth and
um what's constructed what's implied in
this headline is that critical race
Theory black lives matter all of the
things that we associate it with with
contemporary struggles are excess you
know they don't belong they're not
needed they're unnecessary
um and that we can do away with them
right
um at that moment you know we have an
assault not just on critical race Theory
we also have an assault on critical
pedagogy critical thinking literacy that
should alarm all of us you know no
matter our disciplines right there's a
way in which you know focusing on
African-American studies makes it seem
as if it's a special
uh object a specialized Target but this
is actually a pretty General assault on
all education and critical literacy so
those are the things that stood out for
me as a teacher yeah
yeah and it's such an important move
there to kind of reduce a course to
Simply content right to Simply mastering
a body of content that's not a that's
not just a um
a subtle shift in what's Incorporated
right that's announcing what a class is
for and what it's not for right and you
sit there uh all right Jason all the way
in the end with your own microphone
what did you see yes and I'll just say
also Jason you've you know written a lot
obviously about
public goods man
um about you know currents of fascism
which seems Not Another Time Another
Place how they show up how they shape
um these events uh so yeah what what
stood out to you so
um two things stood out uh first uh my
my work on fascism is based in the black
intellectual tradition the way that
theorists from Langton Hugh Langston
Hughes to Angela Davis to Tony Morrison
have talked about fascist practices in
the United States like Banning books
restricting education and the person who
has taught me most about that is my
colleague Rod Ferguson who was declared
uh whose work was declared as having no
educational value so that's deliberate
to declare the sources of Education as
having no educational value that's
intentional uh and the second thing that
really struck me me just in terms of the
paradoxicality of it all was that
Kimberly Crenshaw was coming to get the
Winslow medal at my University the
highest medal given by Yale School of
Public Health uh four Concepts such as
intersectionality which were being
banned from the curriculum in Florida as
having no educational value so no
educational value means obviously very
high educational value
thanks Jason uh
Professor blight you know a lot of your
work is is
um gives us a historic context to
understand moments of uh revanchism
right reclaiming something that seems
lost from reconstruction
um the kind of national reunion quote
unquote that followed what what did you
see that that caught your eye first of
all I've never used that fancy word
revengeism in print it's yours I need to
think about that now uh first of all uh
amazing turnout thank you all for I see
a lot of my students former students
incredible
um teachings are alive and well how
about that
um
let me just describe what I experienced
this week and you know in a little
chronology first of all I agree the
headlines could be one hell of a lot
better
um but here's what happened
a week ago today I got an email from
David Coleman the head of the College
Board and two of his assistants asking
me to endorse the course the course
I said well fine but I'd like to read it
first
[Music]
his initial point was that I should just
have confidence in the people who are
the lead Consultants now those are good
friends of mine but still want to read
something before you blurb it uh the
next day they sent me uh the course
turns out the course I read
is the final one that they were about to
release on Wednesday the one with the
excise eight or ten sections from the
last part I didn't know that
on Monday
uh I wrote an endorsement
uh mostly about academic freedom I just
said that the usual things about
academic freedom I said this is what
this is about and I said something like
no State Legislature Governor or board
of education has any business
messing in I didn't use the word messing
but in in course curriculum for the
public schools period
and
then that afternoon and let's give a
little shout out to here to some people
in the journalism world who are actually
trying to do their job my own student
and Rose are you here I don't know I
can't tell uh she used to be uh editor
of the Yale daily she's not working for
NBC News she gets me on the phone
as a person to be interviewed not as
their senior essay advisor which I also
am
uh and Rose had
the old version
that have been pirated out and you could
get it finally through the Wall Street
Journal and some other places I had the
final version I didn't know there was an
earlier version
so on the phone for more than an hour
Rose and I are comparing the two
versions
Point by Point by point and I thought oh
uh-huh this looks all excise
so I that afternoon withdrew my
endorsement from Mr Coleman he he
respectfully said thank you I said until
I understand what the hell happened here
no endorsement
then I spent an hour on the phone with
Kim I think that night I can't remember
now just musing about what the hell is
going on I don't know what do you
think's going on uh what about this what
about that we gossiped a lot
about who who actually is Consulting on
this thing
uh and then
one thing led to another to another all
kind you know you get quoted in one
press piece and they all start calling
you
last point about that
I think it's yesterday uh I did an
interview with a guy from The Washington
Post uh Nick Anderson I think his name
is he does higher ed for them
he had gone out and interviewed a whole
bunch of people who had worked on this
curriculum all through last year
uh teachers professors Etc some had just
been asked to critique it others that
actually conceived it to a person
this this was information worth having
to a person they said we were working on
this all last year we were doing all
this long before DeSantis ever said
anything we're not doing this we didn't
make changes you need to know this in
response to DeSantis we made the changes
for substantive reasons now this is what
we can still debate what substantive
reasons why only the stuff at the end of
the course why only the Contemporary
stuff and so on and so forth but it's
not like they just heard
it's simply not true that they they
heard desantis's news conference last
week and suddenly made the changes
that's just not true
I also
am Keen to say and when we come back to
other topics here we're having this
debate on Ron desantis's terms
and we need to think otherwise
now that's not easy because they have
millions of dollars behind this campaign
against public schools they have Koch
brothers money behind this campaign the
educational Community Academia teachers
especially teachers don't have big
lobbies and they don't have big
propaganda budgets
but we need a social movement somehow
tantamount
to the right Wing's attack on public
schools to fight back so that we can
begin to have a debate about this not
just on Ron desantis's terms
and I hope that's the last time I use
his name here
all right well thanks for those initial
snapshots I think they helped give us a
different right putting together like
different pieces of the puzzle that
people had accessed I actually want to
pick up then on something
um Professor polite that you just said I
think one of the complexities of this
decision to offer what Professor
Ferguson described as a certain
articulation and version of the course
is that it allows uh the governor and
the Board of Education to state that
they are not actually explicitly opposed
to teaching black history in Florida
classrooms but that they have an
obligation to ensure that the content is
in their words educationally valuable
so they're actually
um they have a kind of disavowl at stake
right
um and it's also the case that there
have been some prominent Scholars
through different avenues that have
signed off on this version of the course
arguing that's either an incremental
opportunity to introduce important
material to students
or that the content that was left out
was secondary to the curriculum and this
gets to something Dave that you said
that that it was Theory as opposed to
history and so it was a kind of
non-ideological decision colorblind
decision to privilege some content over
others
so for the next round I want us to think
about how you kind of unpack and make
sense of these comments these disavows
this has nothing to do with
um what do they bring to mind for you
what are the underlying links between
the scholars and I think this is really
important for us to think about the
scholars named
and the sets of politics and analytics
and prisms that were at stake in their
work because the official defense is we
had room for 40 we had you know there
were 60 there we just this is a a
product of compromise it has no politics
attached to it
so I actually want to just bring this
back let's start with you David a little
bit to think about the the histories of
disavowel what's what's familiar perhaps
about this this sense that it has
nothing to do with the content with the
political commitments or with race and
producing racial knowledge itself
first this time
for fun to go last but
I
every time you hear somebody say this is
not about politics it's about politics
I mean it is in fact that's what this is
ultimately about it is ultimately about
the elimination of Roderick and Kim's
work and that and kanahasi's essay on
reparations and the unit on on black
lives matter and and the other six or
seven items that were removed but this
is a political discussion this is about
power
this is about who gets to control
education and it's Way Beyond education
and so who gets to control the next
election who gets to control
legislatures
uh so anytime they're dis and the idea
that the College Board come on folks and
I actually there's a lot of good people
who work there they I mean you may not
like these AP tests and courses and and
God help you but uh you know they work
hard on these things uh it's also
billion dollar operation let's remember
that for a non-profit
um
but
they are making political decisions it's
it's really that simple now it it this
business of what's a secondary source
and a primary source here is is a false
distinction
I mean my goodness your work is now
is a primary source good Lord I mean in
a real sense it's because there are
there are ways in which what's written
about something in a time in a moment
becomes over time its own kind of
primary source I mean when Dubois wrote
the last chapter of black reconstruction
the propaganda of history that was the
last chapter of black reconstruction
that is now very much a primary source
and I've been teaching it all my life
okay does that mean I have two minutes
oh cool
um but
um so that's just a false distinction
that and they made that up in in the
absence of something else to say we just
cut out secondary sources no they didn't
there are secondary sources earlier in
the course as well and by the way
there's a lot that's good in those first
three quarters of this course they spend
the first five weeks of this course
on African civilizations African
societies the origins of the African
slave trade uh the beginnings of an
African diaspora and all of its enormous
complexity how many American Kids know
anything about that
it's fantastic and they get five weeks
on it that's good celebrate that but
they made choices to take out what's
contemporary because clearly
the they whoever was making all these
choices in the College Board saw this as
where the controversy would be
and I don't know exactly when somebody
will ferret this out there's a
journalist out there that's going to
figure all this out
maybe even a historian about who did
this and when you know in 2022 uh and
when did they really decide to take
critical race Theory out maybe I don't
know it was in originally and then it's
not
um so also last point
last point
um look I don't what I want to know is
how many teachers were asked
and there were teachers involved in this
process I'm told but how many I don't
know maybe Mary you know how many actual
High School teachers are involved in the
creation of these courses
how many teachers weighed in on what
they teach or what they want to teach or
what they know how to teach
that would be very valuable to know
because they're the people who have to
do it and they do have discretion and
how to T they don't all teach exactly
the same thing on the same day teachers
have discretion in these programs and we
shouldn't talk about this AP
African-American studies courses if it's
it's it's a curriculum from on high that
everybody must do the same
but it is true they made a choice
to make about eight or nine of these
units at the end optional for research
papers
no it could just happen young people are
so interested in this stuff they're all
going to write their papers on it who
knows
thanks David I mean that and that does
raise questions then about teachers that
would choose to foreground those issues
more intentionally they might many might
the vulnerability right there's a kind
of like usage especially yeah and and
particularly for teachers of color and
black teachers who are much more likely
to be viewed with suspicion uh you know
don't you know we laid out the the
directions here and and the the
possibility that you one may have
discretion over some parts right what
what text to use in introducing right
kind of early abolitionist thought right
you know there but especially in this in
the two dozen states that have divisive
concept laws right working with it there
teaching under a divisive concept law
right
um yeah and how that changes the working
conditions of teachers yeah right at a
moment of profound need in public
uh Jason let's turn to you I mean part
of this is also you know history is
about kind of facts yeah it's just
events and what we don't want to do is
impose something right there is a kind
of theory-less History so uh yeah what's
your kind of take on that and kind of
how that allows us to understand or or
not organize our sins of the past yeah
so so no philosopher of History would
ever say history is just a series of
facts history is a narrative structured
by a narrative that's basic to the
philosophy of History uh so the ques the
the the question so really it's all
philosophy when you get
um so uh
yeah
so so you have to ask what narrative are
they trying to eliminate what narrative
are they targeting uh and the narrative
they're targeting is the narrative that
Drew me as a philosopher into the study
of recent U.S history uh for me as a
philosopher uh and this is the main
topic of my 2015 book how propaganda
works I wanted to know how after the
Civil Rights movement after this
movement for Liberation uh racial
Injustice completely persisted mass
incarceration what we now we know
incarcer 200 000 people are serving life
sentences that's basically roughly the
full prison system when I was born
um so how after uh after the Civil
Rights Movement in a country that lauds
the Civil Rights Movement do we have end
up with re-segregation in 2014 2015 last
time I spun the numbers almost 10
percent of the world's prison population
came from the formerly enslaved
population of the United States so the
theorists they're targeting are the ones
that theorize about that
the theorists they're targeting are the
ones that say wait the Civil Rights
Movement didn't solve all the problems
and so that's what they're trying to do
they're trying to say we solved racial
Injustice Martin Luther King that's why
we've got a holiday uh and uh and that's
very clearly what they're trying to do
they're trying to eliminate this any any
studies of the practices and structures
of the institutions
of the police of the of the criminal
legal system
of the school system that results of of
banking that that keeps uh the racial
wealth Gap uh basically what it was
before the Civil Rights Movement uh
Yale's my colleague Jennifer Richardson
from whose work I've learned so much uh
studies the myth of the myth of racial
progress The Narrative of the myth of
The Narrative of racial progress uh uh
white Americans think that uh Black
Americans have 90 percent of the wealth
of uh of of white Americans when they
have 10 of the wealth so the what
they're trying to do is they're trying
to make an explicable black movements
for social justice they're trying to
make it so that when you see a protest
you're like what are they complaining
about we have Martin Luther King Day
um so uh so so it's very clear to me
what they're trying to do they're trying
to remove all structural uh any kind of
study of structures and practices uh
that persist and make us think that
because we have Martin Luther King day
we did it
um so and and finally I want to note on
the I want to end on this question of no
political content which as David said
you know the most political content of
all is saying that you have no political
content so as you all know from your
arguments in your dorms but suppose that
suppose that somebody said we're going
to make illegal the concept of sexual
harassment
suppose someone said uh and and suppose
like 18 states passed laws making it
illegal to teach the concept of sexual
harassment you couldn't mention it you
couldn't talk about it nobody would be
fooled about what's going what's going
on right
so why has there not been an outcry
about the concept of intersectionality
um sexual harassment affects black women
white women all women intersectionality
is only about
a subset of women
um is it because uh it's about that
subset that there isn't the outrage uh
that there should be okay
thanks Jason and I think there's you
know there's a couple things there one
is saying there's a clear relationship
between the content of a history course
and how you understand what's natural or
not in the world it orients your
expectations your desires your hopes uh
it very much allows you to discern or
not discern things that's partly what's
at stake and the taking away of a
particular kind of framework actually
denies right a whole subset of students
you know Baldwin in his you know talk to
teachers that says this students see
everything they see the inequalities
they see the humiliation they you know
they see the possibilities they come to
classroom asking what's happening here
and the notion that a teacher would be
told
we can't talk about that or or what
you're seeing is just as your other
example it's just random if you see
someone you know humiliated it's likely
their fault yeah so you're you know and
and that produces a certain kind of
understanding and that's not power
neutral in that way so that's that's
really helpful
um Rod let's turn to you now
um I'm also very much thinking about
your work on student movements and
reminding us about the capacious
imagination they had for these classes
and and how you might put that into
dialogue with what we're seeing now
yeah I mean you know
um you know if we think about the
[Music]
um
student protest movements but also just
the general social protest movements at
the end of the 60s the beginning of the
70s you know what we saw
actually
um and contrary to the popular narrative
is that the Black Panthers were in
conversation with the Gay Liberation
folks Marsha B Johnson Sylvia Rivera
um the members of Street transvestite
action revolutionaries
um in conversation with Huey P Newton
Newton writing the communique about
women's and Gay Liberation right the
didactics house in Philadelphia learning
from and producing their own kind of
socialist lesbian anti-racist feminism
the kombahi river Collective so all of
these groups were in conversation with
each other being inspired by each other
trying to learn from one another and
also them producing a kind of
cartography of struggle yeah right and
here we are now
with an edict to abolish
those cartographies right this is what
that's about right it's um the reason
that we're targeted you know that our
colleagues Angela Davis
um you know Robin Kelly targeted it's
because you know people have been
working to produce cartographies so that
we can make links that's what
intersectionality is you know
how do I
think about the links between modes of
difference and histories that are
supposed to be disconnected from one
another
that's the threat all right that's the
worry
that people are actually producing
Frameworks by which they can see the
links between things right that they're
not discreet entities that they are
overlaps that they are affinities and if
we do that then there might be the
possibility that there could be strange
affinities unlikely alliances you know
between those groups you know
that's what strikes Terror
in the heart
s of these folks okay
rod that's so important and moving
because I think it also pushes us past
so we can say there's an edict I think
is a helpful term here right because
they're disavowing edict but the
elimination of a queer presence in the
curriculum of a feminist intersectional
one could read as well that's a kind of
it's simply bias and they're just they
need to be more open to it but you're
saying it's not just that it's not just
you know because one could even imagine
in a corporation of a presence that's
not doing that work there so there's
something much more at stake in the in
the kind of purging of those bodies of
knowledge it never happened and it's not
something you have available to think
with
um okay Kim let's turn to you now to to
think also about this question of
History actually can I just want to
intersperse a comment from desha so
Dasha brabham who is supposed to be on
the panel is a windsor High School
teacher she teaches a blacks black and
Latino studies course in Connecticut
um and she wrote in in preparation after
she realized she wasn't able to come
what an immediate effect in the
classroom of these policies is to
further distort students reality of the
past and present one of the rationales
put forward by the College Board is that
by taking away the more theoretical
aspects of the curriculum but that same
rationale is not being applied to the
ideas of James Madison and Alexander
Hamilton who are also producing theories
on government the product of this is to
imply further that black people are not
contributors or capable of theory or
thought
one of my students recently wrote a
paper comparing crenshaw's ideas on
intersectionality to another 20th
century thinker these exercises are
essential if you're going to teach about
James Madison's ideas on Democracy then
it's equally essential to consider
Angela Davis's ideas on abolition
democracy
so I you know and you talked about this
today and you're about to Public Health
about the the
um
kind of re-energizing of ideas about
racial superiority and inferiority that
come about in these disavowed settings
but let's turn to you now to kind of
help us think about these histories yeah
well and let me add the
assumption is also that students can't
learn about democracy they can't learn
about uh the government they can't learn
about the state from the experiences
that prompted them to want to have this
course in the first place so some of the
irony I guess we might call it in the
story is that the very conditions of
possibility that opened up uh this
course
um the the the aftermath of George Floyd
and and Brianna Taylor the Contemporary
uh dimensions of the histories
that's precisely the information that's
precisely the thinking that has now been
rendered optional and I just want to say
as far as teachers are concerned what
this also does is to tell teachers
um you can teach this at your own peril
it deprives them of the ability to say
no this is part of the AP curriculum so
it's effectively saying to teachers who
have now been subjected to in in many of
these states that have memory laws
surveillance in the classroom
uh fines the possibility of being sued
losing their jobs and then beyond that
losing their license is not just losing
their jobs but losing their license so
what this has done is deprived them of
some institutional capacity to say what
I am doing is authorized what I am doing
is legitimate what I am doing is
important to the educational project so
I want to say that that part of the
conversation about when did it happen uh
whether the the teachers were consulted
there is an interesting
um problem in whether they've been
consulted because right now the course
has not been fully taught the
information that has to they're halfway
through so what are you going to consult
the teachers about about this stuff
that's taken out because they haven't
even had an opportunity to teach it in
in law that that that's called you know
sort of contradictory evidence right but
what I want to suggest is even our focus
on did they do it a couple of weeks ago
or have they done it for a whole year is
a problematic framework because it makes
it seem as though the damage that's done
is only damage if someone intended it to
be done it's only damage if it's
intended to be in response to desantises
claims last week but in critical race
Theory one of the things we do is
suggest that damage is done whether it's
intended or not damage is done whether
it happened last week or last year
damage is done right because effectively
what this has created is a course that
basically gives the students letters
from ancient history but doesn't give
them the grammar to put it together into
meaning in the here and now so what does
it mean to say yeah we had a lot of
history in it but we decided not to say
anything or not to make the movement for
black lives a legitimate topic that is
required in the course what does it mean
to say okay we might have talked a
little bit about World War II and maybe
we talked about the federal Housing Act
depriving black GIS of the same kind of
access to to housing in suburbs maybe it
meant that they didn't get the same
opportunity as white people did but what
we're not talking about is that
deprivation of that opportunity in the
40s and the 50s has now ballooned into
billions of dollars of wealth that white
gi's were able to get and pass on to
their kids that that that ygis were able
to pass on the black gi's word
our students in this course won't be
able to really talk about that because
that has to do with contemporary
inequalities and the whole point of this
attack is to say we can talk about
history as much as we want but where
we're drawing the line is in saying that
that has anything to do with the here
and now because if it has something to
do with the here and now it implicates
what people need to be doing in the here
and now to really make good on the
Promises of equity and inclusion and
that's precisely what divisive concepts
are are basically against so I I just
want to say that that that part of this
um debate that that that they're having
is kind of affirming the very ideas that
they don't want in it in the first place
right they're affirming the idea that it
only counts if we did it because
DeSantis told us to not it counts
because we are depriving a new
generation of the education they need to
understand the lives that they've been
born into
mm-hmm
[Applause]
I think and I just want to bring in
Dacia one more time and then we'll go to
the third part because it speaks you
know directly to that the question of
what historical knowledge can be
mobilized to do
um outside of just events and so desha
comments Carol Anderson a really
important historians book White rage is
essential for us to see that these
attacks are not new but should be
expected behind every civil rights gain
lies an attack the fact that many are
unaware of the struggle behind the
aftermath of brown V board or the
removal of troops after the
Reconstruction amendments demonstrate
yet another indictment on the education
system that we are consistently not
telling the whole story treating these
winds as the products of individual
characters or inevitable success when
the truth is that the it was the product
of decades worth of organizing in
communities so I think it's just another
astute way of saying you can actually
take the same kind of like line on the
timeline event and the framework with
which it's discussed and engaged with
students makes all all the difference
right all the difference
we're not going to go to our last round
and we'll continue to invite you to put
your questions there as we put those
together
um yeah we have those here and here
we're trying to really think about where
do we go from here
um so I'd like each of you to think
about your sense of two roads that might
lead from this moment
the first in which this decision is
simply endorse accepted maybe some
hand-wringing but otherwise with little
objection
either because it's pragmatic to do
simply we have to accept the conditions
or it's just not worth the fight it's
actually not it's not relevant to other
concerns
what happens
and what danger does it promise Beyond
Florida high schools
the second
in which we see this as a moment that
requires concerted and Collective action
what might that action look like and
what kinds of Futures could we
potentially build
and for this Rod we're going to turn to
you first if that's all right
all right one
um object to it
right simply object to it as you're
objecting to it go back to Martin Luther
King's letter from the Birmingham Jail
okay in that letter
uh he defines theorizes
direct action right and says why direct
action is needed when a society refuses
to come to grips with its historical
moment
creative tension has to be produced
the creative tension can be produced
through Collective mobilization right
the use of the body
the use of cultural forms cultural
practices read that and then do
something with it okay
ironically the other thing that we can
do that
the DeSantis folks say they want
that will actually go a long way
read and write
okay so the stuff that I want you to
read read it
okay the things that they are saying
should not be read imagine that as a
list of recommendations
you know as a syllabus in and of itself
you know pass those on to other people
all right produce the classroom outside
of the classroom
right in your dorms
uh in your clubs with your families all
right let's take back that moment uh
when it was illegal for instance for
black people black enslaved people to
read and to write so what did they do
they had things like midnight schools
all right
where they produced critical education
you know
away from
you know the Masters purview right
produce those multiply them
and also demand that that curriculum
belongs also in public education
you know
in K-12
and that it also it belongs in
University settings because that's
what's coming next
you know
don't be lulled into thinking that this
will just stay
with K-12 teachers okay you know
the other Target will be
higher education we already see that
with this answers uh saying that he is
going to go after diversity equity and
inclusion
units you know within colleges and
universities all right so that's what's
at stake multiply the instances and
moments and context for critical
education get involved produce your own
direct action right
it only takes a handful of folks
you know what did Audrey Lord say
find your work and do it
period
[Applause]
thanks Roger before we go to Jason I
just want to underscore right of course
the notion that there might be some
um robust version of African-American
studies ethnic studies at Yale at
another place even as the rest of the
you know that that is no ethics studies
that is no right it's completely
antithetical and even for in higher ed
you know graduate students pursuing
teaching and research jobs you know
teachers wanting to go into the field
all of this will affect you people were
working on abolition right all of these
topics have now been subject to censure
I never thought in 15 years I would work
with a graduate student in these fields
and advise them before they give their
ethnic studies job talk they might have
to tone down the the politics and the
transformation the whole purpose yeah
was that this was the field that these
things could be where the knowledge
could be produced right so so the the
fact that we're they're now saying that
the discipline is coming here no one is
exempt from that
um Jason let's turn to you now in that
sense two roads what both the
um what happens if we don't act and what
are the possibilities if we do
hate to be Debbie Downer but but that's
kind of my work uh what happens if we if
we don't take the kind of Route Rod
suggested I I think I I think Danny you
phrased it a little too optimistically
like you were like oh well you know if
it's just ethnic studies being free at
Yale but it's not free elsewhere in
public universities then you know it
still will affect us indirectly no it'll
come for Yale too It'll like like that's
one thing if you look internationally uh
you might think oh they'll just stop at
the public universities and it's already
well beyond K through 12. uh Texas
lieutenant governor said he's going to
uh fire all the University of Texas at
Austin faculty who teach critical race
Theory who teach I taught Tim Snyder and
I taught Angela Davis on Tuesday in our
class uh so that would be illegal we'd
be fireable and for the University of
Texas at Austin which is so supposed to
be a great University so it's already
coming for Public Schools public
universities and we can and you might
think okay but we're at private
universities we're safe
or Bond Victor or Bond already figured
out how to deal with that problem uh he
he got he got central European
University using various legalities to
close up shop the best university in
Hungary a private university he got them
to close up shop and uh and move to
Vienna uh so uh so and they're imitating
dissent they're descendants they're
imitating Orban because our bond was the
speaker at the keynote at the national
conservatives conference and he was very
skilled at taking over the courts and
targeting private concerns he forced the
whole Free Press to sell itself to his
friends by suddenly everybody faced
enormous tax bills and there if you
listen to JD Vance whose talk at the
national conservatives conference was
our enemy uh our enemy is the professors
I believe it was called
um uh the idea was that they're they'll
get they're theorizing very explicitly
how to get go after the private
universities they'll uh they'll go after
our endowments they'll go after well I'm
in favor of that but um uh but but
they'll they'll go after yeah they'll go
after Federal funding uh they'll they'll
go after there's a number of ways they
can play with tax codes uh there's a
number of ways uh they can they can
imitate what what's happened in Eastern
Europe uh here with privates as well so
it's gonna they're gonna come after
everybody and this is a corporation too
and so just like the College Board they
care about profits here too so uh
don't be fooled uh so the goal is as as
Professor Crenshaw said that you look at
present events and be baffled so that's
their end goal
um and what they're doing if you look at
what we let happen in the United States
uh there's a book called Laboratories of
of autocracy about States like Wisconsin
North Carolina where basically the
United States is like okay let's have a
little Hungary inside the United States
where the state where if the Democratic
governor wins the state legislate
gerrymandered in state legislature will
vote to strip the governor of his powers
every time they have a Democratic
governor in Wisconsin and North Carolina
that's what they do and at first
everyone was outraged and everyone's
like okay that's just Wisconsin and
North Carolina we can't let this happen
because once you let it happen uh you
know everyone's like well it's just like
that state it's just another state so
we've done it already with State houses
we've done it with gerrymandering we've
done it with our our Congressional uh
our our Congress people in North North
Carolina gerrymandered maps they're
trying trying to you know 50 50 vote
Democrat Republican but you know uh you
know 75 percent of their represent
Congress people are Republicans so we
can't let it happen with education great
thank you Jason
again remind you to look at the to
um message text your questions so that
we have uh
before we get to uh David and Kim to
close us out just going to bring dation
one more time on this last Point
um who says although the recent attacks
of CRT are making mainstream there are
more silent attacks happening every day
in the underfunding of schools the
removal of elective courses for students
that often expose them to classes such
as AP African-American history being
removed because of a lack of Staff Etc
the attack on education is far-reaching
and we cannot lose in this debate and
then we must now remain Vigilant and use
the community framework to work together
Collective action Community activist
projects to address the educational
malpractice we see in Florida and across
the country in the words of James Brown
we need to get up get into it and get
involved
parents students teachers administrators
and families in the community together
to mediate and strategize the short and
long-term effects of the Strat of this
attack we need an all hands on deck
strategy right and I just want to say
it's again to the point of like teachers
who are experience this most acutely and
profoundly understand the landscape and
see it in in as a matter of academic
freedom for sure but also deeply tied to
many other Transformations that they and
their students experience uh David uh
we're going to turn to you and then
finish with Kim uh two roads which way
well your first road is not an option
I think we're all saying that and Dacia
if you're watching thanks for setting me
up because I want to talk about public
schools
[Music]
a lot of us met Deja last fall at our
conference here that the Guilderland
Center did about
teaching slavery and race
and we
we celebrated teachers to say the least
I come back to the public schools
you know
and I want to endure well I want to
endorse the David Pepper book that you
mentioned about state legislatures that
that's an extremely important book to
read if you want to understand what's
really happened to American politics the
action is in the states folks it's not
as sexy run for State Legislature isn't
that exciting
you want an interview with the state
legislature
no you don't you want to interview with
an ibank
sorry anyway
uh but we need you in the state
legislature and all right all right
enough of that but that book by David
Pepper is brilliant
uh first of all I went back I'll do this
real quickly
one thing we need to know here is that
African-American studies is a deep old
tradition
it's 55 to 60 years old as a curriculum
phenomenon
this is a little bit memory lane and it
makes me old which I am
but I first taught an afam intro course
in 1988 at Harvard where I spent two
years we were just inventing a new
version
and that summer of 1988 I was privileged
to be part of an nah like three week
workshop on how to create introductory
courses in African-American studies it
was a and I just dug a whole bunch of my
old files it was fun
we had experts most of them now dead
we had James Gibbs the Anthropologist we
had El rabito the greatest historian of
black religion we had all kinds of
people come we had when Julius Wilson
come and spend a whole day talking about
social Urban sociology on and we had
Hazel Carby come and talk about
literature and women it was phenomenal
and what we learned is this whole field
began really in anthropology it began in
the great debates over herskovitz and D
Franklin Frazier and what's African
about African-American culture which is
a never-ending debate it's fascinating
stuff we we ended with a whole long unit
on black literature and in the middle an
incredible unit unit we spent days on
this on the historiography of slavery
which Circa late 80s was was still
booming in a certain way it's still
booming and and we created courses you'd
be amazed at the readings on these
courses
uh the tradition is so deep
and sometimes you just need to tell
people that this isn't brand new just
because the AP is creating a course on
it for God's sake and then I moved to
Amherst College where we have black
studies 11 which was our introduction to
Black studies we team taught it it's one
of the most most fun experiences I've
ever had teaching was like three
colleagues at once we had to have a
historian a philosopher and a literary
critic all weighing in on this and my
goodness it was rich sometimes we'd have
students in the class you know they'd
have to read this and read them that it
was intensive reading and they'd say can
we just talk about what it's like to be
black at Amherst
no we'd say do the reading
we can talk about that later if you want
but you know you all know that situation
uh here's the syllabus but here's my
life
and we found out we had to put a little
more time in on that sometimes
uh anyway I'll spare you any more of
this memory lane but this is a deep old
tradition and it's gone through all
kinds of permutations and changes
last point
good I got a minute
Roderick is absolutely right organized
organized politically
this is a political question of power
we need a social movement in the United
States tantamount to black black lives
matter and even bigger it needs sorrow
level of funding and more to save
preserve enhance the public schools 85
percent of Americans are educated in a
public school I went to nothing but
Public Schools I taught seven years in a
public high school I have no education
without Public Schools the public
schools the most democratic thing the
United States ever invented
and there is a
multi-billion dollar crusade to destroy
them
yeah
look
um
by enslaved black people that's where
the Public's education system comes from
well it does in great part they were
right yeah yeah yeah no it does it does
it does although they were trying to
create these things in Massachusetts
earlier too and they did one state
mandated Public Schools before the Civil
War so you're right but hey you want a
new social movement
save the public schools
and go teach
[Applause]
all right Kim
um
we're going to get some you know
questions here but yeah we're at this
moment
we've heard what's at stake and we've
heard generally and broadly you know
where we need to go but I'm hoping you
can also help us kind of deepen that a
little bit and talk about both and
certainly related to the aapf's work
what are the campaigns what are the
possibilities the alliance is that help
to build that yeah so
um I want to start where David left off
and raised the question
um this campaign that we've been part
that we've been witnessing over the last
couple of years
um it hasn't been uh mysterious about
what its objectives were they've said
straight up they're they're hoping to
sow dissatisfaction with public
education in order to dismantle it and
they're starting with the Frameworks
that they know people are most
ambivalent about in the people that
people feel less
concerned with right so where has
everybody been for the last two years
with this divisive Concepts idea where
has everybody been with the attack on
critical race Theory where has everybody
been in this notion that education is
meant to make people feel good this is
like Mega education to make America
great again you've got to believe that
it used to be great for everybody and
the only way you can sustain that is to
erase the parts of the history that were
not great where has everybody been while
this is going on it's not about what
happened last week it's about what has
been generated for the last two years at
minimum so what it makes me question is
whether we are moving to another moment
which I I call Race McCarthyism where
there's a set of ideas that people say
are toxic radioactive anyone that has
anything to do with it anyone who cites
anyone has anything to do with them
Anyone who reads those ideas they are
dangerous people
and the rest of us
will sometimes just disavow those ideas
and those people so think about what the
conversation has been for the last two
years when it's come up is critical race
Theory being taught most people are like
oh no no
we're not teaching critical race Theory
now you actually look at what they're
actually saying and doing they're
um they're they're they're exactly it's
it's a it's a matter of what it's called
right but here's the thing you cannot
outrun what it is because what they're
after is not the name but the set of
ideas so if you're teaching those ideas
if you're talking about structural
racism you're not going to be saved by
saying but it's not critical race theory
if you're saying that current inequality
is in part the product of the past that
is neutrally institutionalized
everywhere you're not going to be saved
by it once they get done with people who
are clearly critical race theorists our
history tells us they come after the
next group
all history tells us they come after the
next group American history European
history you can broaden it to other
histories as well so we know this but
we're not acting as though we know this
and I want to ask the question why is is
it is it because it's about difficult
conversations that everybody has a hard
time with so there's a little bit of
yeah you know what that kind of race
stuff can get kind of hard maybe we
shouldn't be talking about it maybe
there really is a there there that I
don't have to worry about because it's
just about that whatever people thought
up until last week they should not be
thinking it anymore because it's
abundantly clear that this isn't about
whether you call it critical race Theory
intersectionality it's about education
that allows people to understand the
historical groundwork upon which this
contemporary society and all of its
inequalities are based and if we cannot
name that if we cannot talk about it if
we cannot
frame it whether it's through Theory or
narrative we are unable to change it and
that is exactly the point so now that we
know that
now that it's clear what they're going
after and let's be clear DeSantis also
said he's going after diversity equity
and inclusion on campuses he's going
after courses he's going after
professors who he doesn't want to
testify use their knowledge to testify
in law cases around civil rights so this
is a Total Takeover of the knowledge
producing industry
so what are we going to do about it
right now I will say that one of the
things that has been surprising to me is
how little
colleges presidents administrators have
thought that they needed to say anything
about this like where are the presidents
where are the people to say it's time to
do something and defend our institution
and the project that we have been about
now what I know what I've heard what
I've seen is that there's a reluctance
to get involved a reluctance to be seen
as political but it it it's kind of like
you know when someone's coming to burn
down your house for you to say I'm not
going to throw some water on it because
that would be political that's just
suicide when people are coming after the
very mission of your Institution for you
not to defend it is to basically give
them the keys to the house and that's
effectively what I think is happening so
um where where does this go if we don't
intervene I think we know where it goes
you know history tells us where it goes
the only thing is we probably believe
that we are immune because we are the
United States of America and that stuff
doesn't happen here
my only response to that is that just
shows you don't know our history because
that stuff has happened here it was
called Redemption
this is real
so
part of what the African-American policy
Forum has done is we've tried to take a
a page out of History we've tried to
create something that we call the
Freedom Writers uh and freedom readers
book tour
our analogy was that Freedom Writers
these are the folks in the 60s who put
their their bodies on the line to fight
against segregation
um and their understanding of what they
were doing was you know power doesn't
get to tell us where to sit
where to eat where to study where where
where where where where to to pray
um just like power didn't tell Freedom
Writers where to go where to be how to
vote
today they don't get to tell us what to
read
what to write what to learn what to
teach
and if we allowed them to tell us what
to read and what to teach they're
telling us who we can be
and that cannot be what all of this
movement for the last 60 years has been
about we cannot come to this point where
we're willing to pass on a legacy that
is half full or a baton that cannot be
reached by the Next Generation so we
created a book tour we took 19 of the
titles that have been banned in states
around the country and we gave them away
we we said if they don't want you to
read it you should take it as a reading
list and better yet we're going to be
your Amazon we're going to bring it to
you
which is exactly what we've been doing
and we have found that when we are
talking directly to people we're not
trying to mediate through the media
saying well actually you know critical
race theory is the legal infrastructure
behind structural racism when we're not
trying to talk to them but we're
actually talking to people and saying
the reason why your neighborhood is
under sourced and underfunded is because
of your ZIP code it's because of the
zoning it's because of the tax basis
because of the federal Housing Act we
are making it clear and plain that what
people wake up to every day is not based
on what they've done or their choices
it's based on what our society has put
into play and how it's structured for
the future when you tell people that
directly they understand it they support
it and they get mad that people are
trying to take it away from them so what
what we're all about is like I am all
about go teach I am about taking this
information to families I am about
political activation but not just in the
small D way not even the Big D way but
in the way that says if we do not fight
for our democracy right now we will not
have it to fight for in the future and
that is what I think is at stake it
might look like it's just about a little
thing right now it might look like it's
just about AP it might look it's like
it's about intersectionality critical
race Theory queer Theory but trust if
they are successful in the red States
and in some sections in the blue States
and making this the law it will be the
future that we will inherit and I
frankly don't think that that's what we
want
foreign
we have a couple of minutes left
um and I just want so my understanding
is the reception we'll have some of
those books we'll have materials about
the campaigns how people can get
involved in them a chance to talk to the
staff about those possibilities
um a couple of questions here and and
this and I'm just going to go one more
the first word from Dacia was the
College Board is not our friend
um and you know the defense of them or
the surprise that their Speedy flip-flop
demonstrates a more significant issue at
hand as to what these attacks were meant
to cause she actually says and I think
this is really helpful they were meant
to cause us to be reactionary
by which I think it also means right to
think about who who among us we should
be suspicious of despise Etc right
whatever an anti-solidarity
um there's a couple of questions that
are actually focused on the very project
of AP classes which before this we know
are a part of a system of sorting deeply
and Equitable in terms of what has
access to them reproducing racial
hierarchies so how how I want to just
invite you to all say a little bit maybe
just to start with Rod on the one hand
we don't want to say this this is
insignificant because it's simply uh you
know it'll kind of elite the box of
courses but on the other hand as you
said the only way to learn this is not
simply through an AP class so how do you
think about that and uh yeah the kind of
the relationship between the class on
these broader the broader histories and
genealogies of black studies
we're at a moment where this is not just
about the AP course right this is about
the Integrity of Education
you know at this uh historical juncture
right
um I mean I will say that
you know
I didn't answer the emails from the
College Board
uh last year and all the time that they
were sending me those emails because
it's the College Board yeah
yeah
um I want the SAT to go away yeah you
know
yeah
I do not think that is it is in keeping
with uh
the history of black Progressive thought
which let's face it that's the that's
the dominant of black history I mean
black and Electro history is black
progressives you know I mean you can
talk about like the conservatives and
whatever but what are you gonna do with
the rest of those weeks yeah
and so
you know so uh I do not think that uh
what we need to have is a more Elite and
now watered down experience
with black studies that is not in
keeping with black studies CLR James
said that black studies is the critique
of Western Civilization
okay he didn't say it was the purview of
those who with with high gpas
you know you didn't say that all right
so this is a radically democratic
project and we need to preserve that and
insist upon that okay
thank you
um maybe uh just a question for David
which is also about
the possibilities and imperatives to
also transform the way U.S history is
taught
um and as an ongoing site of uh yeah
struggle uh well first of all U.S
history has transformed
in enormous ways in the last decades
it simply has let's not kid ourselves
now
does that always trickle down to the
high schools of course not I've been
teaching summer institutes for secondary
teachers for I don't know 27 years or
something I've taught thousands of
they're usually well motivated High
School teachers in the summer they're
hungry they're eager often because they
don't know much
they want they want to take a seminar on
slavery because they didn't learn much
about it
but that doesn't mean they're not ready
to learn and ready to be taught by some
of the best historians so let's not kid
ourselves in fact I wrote this piece
called trust the teachers I guess in the
Atlantic or someplace and I said look
you want to blame somebody for all
that's going on about black history and
race all over curriculums blame us blame
the historians bring it on we'll we'll
take the fight don't blame the teachers
trust the teachers to learn something
last point
we all got to start somewhere
next fall in late September the Gilda
Lerman Center and maybe others here at
Yale
are helping co-sponsor a conference at
Flagler College in St Augustine in
Florida
in what the leader there of this effort
calls behind the red curtain
um now that's a private college although
they are not untied to State monies
because most of their buildings are like
State landmarks so they got some risk to
take and their President is on board
I think
uh but we're working with some some cool
faculty there who want to do it like a
two and a half day knock down drag out
conference about how is history taught
how is Black History taught how should
it be taught we're going to bring in Kim
doesn't know she's coming yet
we're going to bring in Kim Crenshaw and
a whole bunch of other people have
Keynotes but but teachers Florida
teachers with the guts to show up and
that's a question we had some Florida
teachers here at our conference last
fall who were frankly afraid to come
they can't even they're not they're
afraid to use their emails
even in state universities I have three
former PhD students who teach in state
universities in Florida I emailed them
and said what are you all doing aren't
you going to surround the capital and
raise hell and they said I'll answer you
on my Gmail
so this is kind of the way they live
every day
uh but but let's not kid ourselves but
what happens in the academy
the history we change all the time and
rewrite and rewrite and argue like hell
with each other and sometimes it gets
into good textbook usually it gets in
good textbooks usually it gets out
sometimes in synthetic works of
narrative we hope and it gets out in
biographies but the task is to convert
these explosions of knowledge we have
had in the academy
for two three generations
to the public schools
to the public who wants to read that's
still our task I don't have any perfect
formulas for doing that but at least
when you get tenure
get the hell out of your own campus and
talk to real people
because they actually do want to learn
something
and even before you get tenure
and and thank you David
but come down St Augustine in late
September We're Going To Raise Hell
behind the red curtain
we have we're going to do two more quick
questions I have a short question for
Jason and then we're going to turn it to
Kim to leave up I should also say
Obviously where we are in New Haven
there's a public school system with
Dynamic teachers incredible students
that's been consistently consistently
denied the resources it needs yes and
and a a very powerful and growing
movement among teachers parents and
students to insist you know the same
things that are being said there that
are exist in our own state which has
among the deepest racial inequalities in
economic disparities so I hope everyone
is also on the lookout for that work
because there's concrete opportunities
and we we know in this institution at
Yale have Consciousness that many of
those disparities are linked to the
resources we have because of the taxes
that we don't cut into it so
there there's a version of that right
that we have to account for here as well
I want to just a quick question to Jason
and some final words from Kim history is
one side of these contestations but
there's many other disciplines sometimes
people think let's say discipline like
Classics well by its nature right all
the classics folks you're excused this
doesn't involve you right but in fact
that's the very site where certain
authoritative forms of racialized
knowledge are constituted so can you
just say a little bit more about those
and then we'll turn to cancer
hard on this he's saying we're going to
do classical education we're going to
have
and uh now this is something I learned
from my friend Charles Mills who said
you know who's channeling Plato now uh
it's the black intellectual tradition
who's doing philosophy of education and
my philosophy of education class I begin
with Plato and I end with bell hooks
um because in the 20th century who is
talking about education in a political
system it is the people denied that
education those are where the
conversations are happening so you uh
there's if you're going to teach
classical education in the 20th century
that's really going to end those
questions those set of questions when
Plato and the Republic says when he's
asked what's the first question of
Justice in the city what's the first
issue he says how you educate people and
who in the United States writes about
education who are the great education
theorists well it's starts with an
argument I mean it goes you know Anna
Julia Cooper uh uh Du Bois all the way
uh to Bell hooks so uh and Beyond that's
a conversation those classical questions
uh those are the black intellectual
Traditions so don't let them take the
classical tradition from you great thank
you
yeah
um all right
this has been amazing Kim right it's
really really
um and obviously more to come
there is a question here but I don't
that points out DeSantis is a Yale
graduate I think David Coleman
what's going on here
but I think there's a way that the the
question you know a cynicism can take
over us right we think like we're simply
like nothing can be done other than to
just we're so deeply in entrenched in
the kind of belly of it what's a role
and what part of what the question made
me think about was the legacy of
critical race Theory which actually
emerges from similar institutions
but actually challenges contests and
says what you're doing is not it's not
just we want more from it we have a far
far uh more expansive sense of what
education is for than the parochial
mediocre education you're providing us
so could you just as we like help us
think maybe about from these sites right
what what those lessons might teach us
about the the connections we can make is
there a CRT lesson in here for us
okay Danny um so so you have me trying
to to tell a story in two minutes right
so uh here's here's what where where
I'll start and and hopefully finish with
just a note on Tyree Nichols
um you know one one way in which I think
those of us who are concerned about the
the trajectory of the attack on
education and those who are doing it one
thing that we agree on is that education
um has been and continues to be the key
to transforming this Society the only
difference is a normative difference we
believe in the transformation and they
don't right but we Converge on the
absolute critical dimension of having
access to education and and and the
production of new knowledge right so
um I will say then in about public
education I know you guys have your
debate about it but public education was
the product of freed people
during Reconstruction right the first
thing they wanted to vote the second
thing they wanted was education it was
the thing that was the second thing that
redeemers went after first they went
after the vote and then they burned down
the school houses that really
um uh education the same ones that are
trying to suppress the right to vote we
need to learn about what those
connections tell us about the
significance of Institutions that
produce the knowledge that we need to
sustain our democracy right so these
things have always been one and the same
they've always been connected all sides
or both sides of this agreed to it we
realize that there's a connection
between a past that said if you taught
an enslaved person to read you could be
punished and if you were that enslaved
person you could be punished with death
that tells us that a status quo is
maintained by denying people who are at
the bottom of it the capacity to read
the situation to be literate about it to
be able to change it so that's that's a
continuing uh Dynamic that we're still
in the middle of and we need to be able
to pull those lessons to to the forward
moment now the reality is that we have
made strides as as as you know David has
said these institutions do not look the
same this does not look like the same
I'm sure 30 40 years ago wouldn't have
looked like this right that is the
product of pressure that is the product
of Imagining the university being
different that is the product of
bringing our political
material our political connections all
the things that make for transformative
possibilities to bear that is what
happened
critical race theory is a product of
that
it come it comes from ethnic studies as
applied to law it comes from
African-American studies as applied to
law if we realize that the inequalities
that we Face are not the product of our
own deficits but deficits in our
structures in our institutions then the
question is well how do the different
disciplines that we are in contribute to
that and so we went into law school
asking that question how does law
contribute to naturalizing an unequal
status quo first by depriving
individuals and groups of the ability to
change that and then rationalizing
saying that it's colorblind so it's okay
so effectively the story of critical
race theory is the story of the
institution of Education writ large
young people coming into these
institutions with a different idea about
what the purpose of education is a
different idea about what the mission of
the institution is and a lower level of
tolerance for the failure to get what
they think they deserve out of these
institutions so I I want to suggest that
the story of African-American studies
and ethnic studies and queer studies and
critical race theory that is the history
that we have to bring to bear those are
the stories that tell us that we don't
have to accept the limited parameters of
the education that we have it tells us
that when we coordinate when we make our
demands and when we believe they are
legitimate and we come up with
alternative ways of delivering knowledge
and information we actually change
things so now this is the pushback
against it with every transformative
moment there is a pushback and they're
just happening quicker so 2020
transformative possibility
2022-23 massive pushback once we
understand that this is all part of the
dynamic we don't have to accept this is
just the way things are this is the way
things have been made to be and we yes
can do something about it because we
already have
yeah I'm so grateful for this discussion
where we should announce there's another
uh webinar web event next Wednesday
where many of the same
themes yes and people gonna be a road
show
but yeah to invite you to that to
remember APF is at the center of driving
these campaigns the anti-racist teaching
and learning collective in Connecticut
students for educational Justice
a beautiful bookstore in New Haven close
to our campus possible Futures there are
resources here yeah nothing has to be
done whole cloth everybody please join
me in thanking our amazing people
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]